[Música]
[Aplausos]
sé que muchos de ustedes han preguntado
con la labor del director y normalmente
pues yo estoy del otro lado así que era
fabuloso para mí poder ver sus caras e
intentar descifrar cuáles son nuestros
sentimientos les estaba despertando esta
bella música de antolín border pues
preguntándole a algunos directores de
orquesta que piensan que esta es la
labor del director
un poquito tiránica cambio algunos
músicos de orquesta piensan que es esta
en realidad el director tiene la
posibilidad de ayudar a los músicos no
solamente a comenzar la música a
terminar la música juntos a determinar
qué tan corto largo suave o fuerte es
cada sonido pero sobre todo una labor
muy importante y en la cual ponemos
muchísimo esmero es la de encontrar
todos los sentimientos escondidos en las
partituras y transmitir los a los
músicos
tenemos que analizar mucho la partitura
estudiarla pasar mucho tiempo con esas
partituras tienen que ver todas mis
fotos de paseos familiares con la
partitura al lado mi esposa refunfuñando
siempre porque no abandona la partitura
así que
quisiera que hagamos un experimento muy
muy rápido
qué le voy a pedir a estos fabulosos
músicos de la orquesta filarmónica de
medellín que toquemos tres compases de
esa misma música sin sentimientos para
cuando voy a que escribe esta sinfonía
que se encuentra nueva york ya un par de
meses después de haber salido de su
república checa- que adoraba pero que
tenía un gran reto formar nuevos
compositores de una generación de
compositores norteamericanos así que
tenía mucha nostalgia por su tierra y yo
conozco muy bien esa nostalgia porque
tuve la gran fortuna de tener a un
músico checo en mi casa aquí en medellín
europol anéc quien escapa de la segunda
guerra mundial de república checa viene
a colombia y se radica en medellín así
que conozco muy bien estos sentimientos
pero quiero que ahorita no tengamos
ningún sentimiento de nostalgia
a ver cómo nos va
[Música]
pero si a esto le ponemos todos los
sentimientos de nostalgia que tenemos va
a cobrar una dimensión todavía mayor
[Música]
como si no pudiera sentir la diferencia
espero que me apasiono a mí cuando era
un estudiante de clarinete y piano aquí
en medellín y tomé la determinación de
convertirme en director de orquesta así
que emprendió un viaje mi primera parada
fue nueva york posteriormente viaje a
viena y logré después de una muy
competida audición un lugar en el
conservatorio de viena que era un gran
sueño
y pues fueron muchísimas las obras que
dirigí muchos sentimientos los que pude
transmitir pero hay una obra que
quisiera compartirles a ustedes hoy ya
que marcó un momento importante y
todavía sigue impactando me mucho cada
vez que la hago
en el último año de dirección todos los
directores deben dirigir una lista de
obras con orquesta pero una obra tan
solo una obra que nosotros podemos
escoger
así que todos queremos que sea una obra
totalmente conectada con los
sentimientos con el ser humano con el
alma de cada director
yo había crecido en el medellín de los
años 80s uno de los momentos más
violentos y complejos de la historia
moderna de latinoamérica como todos
sabemos así que ahí estaban esos
sentimientos era muy apasionado y
también
me encantaban los retos muy grandes así
que él tenía que tener unas dificultades
enormes era el primer requisito una obra
muy difícil de dirigir y en esa búsqueda
de maravillosa de la obra maravillosa
encontré una obra que se llamaba el
mandarín maravilloso yo dije esta es con
el título ya ganó y particularmente era
muy difícil de dirigir y además tenía
sentimientos bien particulares la
primera abre la obra con un sentimiento
que todos conocemos por lo menos los que
hemos vivido en urbes los carros yendo
de un sitio al otro una urbe como nueva
york como viena o como medellín suena
más
la oriental con la playa hora pico
la 10 con la del programa más o menos
así es bueno pero además tenemos el
bullicio de la gente al lado de todos
estos carros
de verdad
d
escalofriante pero más adelante en esta
obra viene otro sentimiento que me
interesaría mucho sobre todo después de
tener 20 años y algunos de ustedes la
seducción
pero por cierto está la cámara cuando
mis hijas vean este vídeo es después de
los 40 mi amor
esa seducción estaba por el clarinete
[Música]
no
ah
[Música]
lamentablemente esta seducción no era
voluntaria en la historia una mujer era
obligada por tres ladrones en una
habitación a seducir hombres en la calle
por la ven desde la ventana y cuando se
hubieran ser robados por ellos así que
no era solamente es el seductor carnet
teníamos unas cuerdas que expresaban
todo el temor
de esta mujer incluso la empatía por las
víctimas que subían y eran robadas
porque tenían el mismo grado de
vulnerabilidad escuchamos el temor de la
mujer con la seducción
[Música]
ah
escalofriante desde aquel entonces esta
música me ha cautivado muchísimo
me ha llevado a muchos sitios donde he
podido compartir estos sentimientos así
que ha sido un viaje bien interesante
estar en la orquesta en japon
transmitiendo sentimientos de un
compositor mexicano o ir a alemania con
una orquesta y centrar transmitir
sentimientos de una orquesta de un
compositor colombiano o incluso una
orquesta en el pacífico colombiano con
sentimientos de un compositor italiano
y a mí me gustan mucho las historias así
que quiero contarles una que sé que les
va a gustar mucho hace varios años me
encontraba
hace varios años me encontraba allá hace
varios meses con traba en méxico cuando
la sinfónica nacional de colombia me
invita hacer un concierto en bogotá la
primera obra del programa una obertura
que creo que muchos conocemos la
obertura de el barbero de sevilla
escuchemos la obertura del barbero de
sevilla
[Música]
vamos
una ópera cómica del compositor italiano
giacomo rossini y estar a su apertura
famosa obertura yo voy a bogotá estamos
en ensayos y de repente me llaman a la
oficina de urgencia me dice el maestro
tenemos la posibilidad de ir esta misma
semana a uno de los puertos más hermosos
alejados y un poco olvidados de colombia
tumaco
sería el primer concierto de la historia
de tumaco de una orquesta sinfónica
profesional yo dije me voy a vamos
inmediatamente
claro el programa había diseñado había
sido diseñado para bogotá sin embargo
ahí vamos todos en el avión hércules de
la fuerza aérea amarrados así como
soldados de la música rumbo a tumaco y
se viene un pensamiento a mi mente
que esta obertura de rossini cómica que
acabamos de escuchar era la más indicada
para este concierto por el primero en
tumaco
volvería a pensar eso mismo cuando antes
de comenzar el concierto se reúne este
grupo que vamos a ver en este momento y
empiezan a tocar currulaos en
agradecimiento a nuestra visita
[Música]
y posteriormente rossini yo pensaba si
era la mejor obra si sería esto era para
bogotá adicionalmente en mi afán de
investigar y analizar como decía no es
que mi esposa le guste mucho cuando esté
con la partitura debajo del brazo en una
piscina reuniones familiares pero en ese
afán de buscar el mayor contenido de
sentimientos en la música descubrí que
muchas de las notas que veníamos tocando
durante muchísimos años no habían sido
escritos por o sin algún musicólogo que
se llama alberto zedda me iluminó y me
dijo mire es que esto no es lo que de
rossi me escribió así que me di a la
tarea de cambiar las notas de la obra
sinfónica nacional por esas de alberto
11 da un trabajo de investigación que él
hizo que yo trataba de implementar en
bogotá una cadena para buscar la versión
más apropiada
y ahí estaba con este grupo incluso un
buen amigo mío me hizo esta caricatura
porque cuando le conté la historia se
reía un poco y me dice ahí estoy yo
si se dan cuenta años atrás un poco
asustado para donde me pegó por dónde
voy
e
pero el concierto salió fabuloso y yo
creo que ese fue un momento de
revelación que quiero contarles que
quiero compartirles cuando en frente de
este pueblo de tumaco yo estoy preparado
para ser rossini todos los músicos nos
miramos con el coraje que nos para
caracteriza a todos los músicos y
decimos este es el mejor lugar el hay un
lugar apropiado para traer esta versión
super de excelsa de rossini y luego la
repetimos en bogotá pero tumaco se
convirtió en el centro de ese proceso
esa universalidad de la música es algo
que realmente nos abruma todos los días
como músicos y que seguimos creyendo en
ella así que bueno me agregaron un par
de segundos del final del concierto
disculpa en el audio que no es muy bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un poquito de ayuda del maestro de
ceremonias no no es ahora
tiene que ser un amigo del maestro
ceremonial 7
pero desde esas melodías ancestrales y
energéticas del pacífico colombiano
hacia las melodías de rossini en su
ópera bufa o las melodías escalofriantes
de béla bartók hasta esa bellísima
melodía con que la que empezamos esta
charla del compositor checo con esa
nostalgia todos traen sentimientos y
nuestra labor y de remover esas fibras
dentro de ustedes con estos sentimientos
un alumno del compositor borja que
escribió una letra
yendo a casa going home
algo como así
[Música]
y al final del gong o mayor que tenemos
que subir hacer un esfuerzo más grande
para llegar a casa y dice así
[Música]
o
muchísimas gracias
y la armónica desde allí
[Aplausos]
[Música]